last night with two two of our friends
and it was it was the American Heart
Association you know what it was called
it was called the heart and stroke ball
nobody saw it and I'm like two years old
something new stroke ball
and I took a gummy and there's this
woman up there she's talking about this
this horrible journey of like her kid
was born with half a heart Happy Ending
the kid survived because the American
Heart Association but it just kept going
every time you thought she had the last
operation there was another operation
and as sad as it was and as much empathy
that I had I kept looking up and it said
heart and strokeball and then I would
start laughing and my wife looked at me
and she's going don't
you [__]
you [__] the story and then she goes and
that wasn't even the bad part and I
almost spit take